what do you
think I'm Israel You're the Palestinians
in Gaza
if everyone every one of the people in
Gaza laid down the
arms and stopped attacking what would I
Israel do to
you it's a good
question
nothing they've tried it
five different
times they literally like stop attack
Israel has never not one time in
history initiated any conflict every
single one of those things that you're
pointing to is a retaliatory attack by a
terrorist organization but if that if
those if that was
switched where I Israel you Hamas in
Gaza I take all of my arms and all of my
protection and I laid them down
what would what would Hamas
do they would kill every single one of
us that's what they do that's that's
what they've sworn to do that's that's
their motto and the the the origin of
their existence all the way back to the
Grand Muffy traveling to Hitler to ask
how do we solve the Jewish Problem Like
you want to follow from the Muslim
brother Hamas to the m to the Muslim
Brotherhood all the way back to the
Grand Muti to muad and you see the
origins of like one thing which is how
do I solve the Jewish Problem is to
eradicate and kill them that is what
Hamas came from not the Palestinians not
those poor people stuck in
Gaza but in that problem if all of Hamas
just went away we would have peace if
they laid down their arms and they
stopped murdering innocent civilians and
raping women and killing babies You'
have
peace if the other side laid down their
arms they would all be murdered all
seven and a half million of them until
they just were walking in blood through
the Jordan
River how do you solve this
problem the radicals have to be
eliminated the terrorists have to go
away that is not I'm not I'm not
conflating the Palestinians and the
terrorists those are separate things but
if there's 2 and a half million people
that are living in Gaza that are
allowing 30,000 terrorists to run
them at some point the Olive Branch
cannot be extended from Israel when
30,000 people are using that region to
launch attacks into their Sovereign
Nation and we were talking about the
propaganda that's that exists in America
what about the propaganda that exists in
Palestine I mean what is their thought
oh it's crazy yeah so like did you see
um the hospital that got destroyed well
it didn't really right no it did not
really no but the New York Times said it
did the New York Times said it was
Congress which is insane and they didn't
retract it they they horsey warmer and
and Israel destroyed a hospital yeah um
so evil it's so crazy that they printed
that in the New York Times I that's the
paper of record that's the most
important newspaper that we have in
America in terms of if if we wanted an
objective source of information most
people say what's the best look I used
to deliver the New York Times when I was
a kid and I did it it wasn't even that
profitable I delivered the Boston Globe
was my main newspaper that I delivered
and then I delivered the Boston Herald
as well and then I got a New York Times
route and I was proud of that because
the New York Times was the real
newspaper that intelligent people read
and it was a different it was a
different plastic rapper you got a clear
you got a clear rapper for the heral and
a clear rapper for the globe but for the
New York Times I got a blue rapper and I
was like one of the people that got to
deliver the New York Times and I
remember thinking as like 20-year-old
kid like oh boy I'm delivering the New
York Times and I would and when I would
drop the paper off of these people's
house I like that's a [__] smart
house these people are reading the New
York Times in Boston and I remember
thinking that I was proud of that that I
delivered the best newspaper in the
world really I I did I literally wasn't
that much money and it was a crazy route
because I'd have to go like a mile in
between houses whereas like with the
Boston Globe I'd have like five six
houses on one street that I would drop
off papers
and the New York Times i' have this
[__] crazy route i' have to go all
over the place to get rid of uh 100
newspapers yeah and then now in 2023
they're circulating terrorist
propaganda yeah and with no with no rec
no no repercussions and and and what do
they make do they even print a
retraction do they say we [__] up you
watch you watch a missile get launched
from Gaza you know onethird of all
missiles that are launched from Gaza
land in Gaza you how like think about
how sad that is is that real 28% of
missiles launched from Hamas land on top
of the Palestinian people Jesus Christ
um and obviously they have no ability to
direct any military Target when these
these crappy missiles are being launched
into Israel they're just like populated
area populated I I was I went and did um
a Fox News Stand Up In The City uh
directly north of Gaza that is the most
rocketed City in all of Israel and in
like the one day that we were there we
had like six rocket attack Sirens go off
you know it's the weirdest thing that
the Palestinians are
allowing Hamas to literally kill them
and pillage everything about their
existence from them Hamas is so rich and
so power $70 million from Iran you know
every every humanitarian ship that comes
into the port or right now that is being
brought up through the Rafa gate via
Egypt into the south portion of Gaza the
moment that lands there that is taken
control of by Hamas they then build
underground infrastructure in the
tunnels and they build military
infrastructure and then they turn as
whatever they can into Rockets and the
humanitarian Aid that is supposed to be
distributed to the people they have
control
of like they have to go not the
Palestinians
they have they have been so screwed by
Hamas but the propaganda and by the they
that they encounter in Palestine has to
be insane yeah they
believe that they're on the good
side how how how do how do they sift
through fact from fiction when what
they're being told and being fed is
being fed to them by
Hamas like how do you how do you how how
do they get access to other information
and how do they how do they ever like
organize and discuss this openly without
fear of losing their lives and being
tortured the only time that you had
consistent water and power going into
Gaza was when Israel was controlling
Gaza now that Hamas is running it it is
just it is nightmarish in
there but they're still in charge and
they're being protected and here in the
United States being like called Freedom
Fighters like they are barbaric
murderers and absolute terrorists that
want nothing besides the genocide of
every my when I saw like the lgbtq flags
of lgbtq stands with the with Hamas yeah
mind is blown isn't it hilarious that
have you ever seen that Meme that it
says uh queers for Palestine and then
Palestine for queers
like
yeah they wouldn't live they wouldn't
live there like no hours they'd be
pushed off a rooftop or burnt
alive immediately but they don't but the
narrative in this country is not that
it's which is so strange I don't know
that like there's sort of overwhelming
evidence about approach that they have
to gay people yeah but yet somehow or
another there's this I stand with
Palestine thing that makes you a
progressive go to Tel Aviv as a as a gay
person walk around with your gay pride
shirt with um your husband or a wife of
the same sex nobody will bat an eye at
you nobody cares everybody's like what
up you know like yeah normal man if she
and her wife tried to walk down the road
in in Gaza yeah oh
man it is so this tinder box that is
that region with the West Bank with the
G Heights in the north with Hezbollah
which is being supported by Iran they're
all positioned On the Border you know
with Iraq allowing people from
Afghanistan the Taliban to move through
Taliban being funded by us $40 million
right now is what we're continually
giving them the Taliban why do we do
that died I don't
know I don't
know what's the cynical side of you the
the we want to recognize them as
legitimate government and we are pain
for them to
start to start a democratic process of
like that that is the I think would be
the tagline of what it what we want them
to do what it is actually doing is the
same thing that happens when we release
6 billion to Iran in exchange for
hostages they then take that $6 billion
no they're not using that exact money to
fund terrorism with Hezbollah or Hamas
but I have one bank account that has an
additional $6 billion in it and now I'm
able to spend $6 billion over here to
finance other things that are going to
destabilize the nation that I have sworn
to eradicate Israel and America so like
cool I'll happily give some more money
to they've been planning this for 4
years the cuds like the Iranian Special
Operations guys training and preparing
Hamas advising on how to execute this
how do they get the intelligence to know
what direction they need to fly with
their paragliders which areas which you
don't think they had Scouts in all the
kutzas around Gaza to identify which
houses they're going to be targeting how
did they find all that stuff out the
people that Israel was allowing out of
Gaza to work as agricultural workers
they were going into these areas into
these kabuchi into these houses into
these Villages doing Recons for Hamas so
then when Hamas launched their attacked
on October 7th they had been funded
there's this amazing book called the new
rules of War and the new rules of War
lines out all of the ways that America
is not prepared to fight a war by
non-state actors by corporations by
cartels by um violent extremist
organizations using proxy methods so
like we are at war with
Iran period they are funding every
single group that just attacked our
American base in Syria that attacked our
American base in Iraq that attacked and
killed a bunch of Americans in Israel
that was funded by Iran and trained by
Iran but we don't have the appetite to
try and fight the war that they're
fighting because they're doing it in
just such a we want that World War II
like we want Patton standing on top of a
tank coming across being like there's
raml go and get him like that that war
is never going to happen again and we
are just not ready to fight this new
type of War under these new rules of War
which is fighting non-state actors
fighting proxy wars fighting
corporations funded by governments
fighting cartels that are getting
subsidized by governments all to
destabilize the greatest nation to ever
exist in the man in in the history of
mankind
us you were saying that you think we're
more vulnerable now than we've ever been
before and you're legitimately worried
that the United States might
fall I
am more worried
now because of the lack of preparedness
of the
individual Americans
are fatter than they've ever been they
are even though there's more guns now
owned there are
few fewer per capita owned by individual
with people that train regularly with
them people that are able to provide and
protect for their families all the all
like all the metrics of measurements of
like that family is going to be
okay that is the smallest that it's ever
been and our government right now is
more vulnerable internationally than
we've ever been our military is even
though I'm so proud to to be a service
member I'm you know when the Army tells
me to do something I 100% have no say
whatsoever I got to go and do it and I'm
really proud to be part of the most
elite fighting force on the planet I
think we are the weakest that we've ever
been for a variety of
reasons when you put all of these things
together and you just take a step back
and like the the aggregate like the the
accumulation of all of these different
factors make me be
like holy crap we are
vulnerable the only way to combat that
is the individual to start taking their
own security and preparedness
seriously get less fat get more healthy
go and train go and buy a gun go start
exercising your freedoms like learn what
it means to volunteer in your school so
you have like cool you can't start your
own School cool you you can't homeschool
well get involved in your kid school
like you got to do something because if
we continue down the path that we're in
we're done for like soon not not not in
like a generation like right now I'm
scared I'm drink water Jesus
Christ